iqu
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine autour de
l'actualité et surtout autour du débat
il y a deux médecin éminent sur ce
plateau ce soir bonsoir laurent
alexandre soir car on sait que vous êtes
essayiste et entrepreneurs mais vous
êtes aussi chirurgien et cofondateur
d'ailleurs du site doctissimo vous avez
revendu depuis vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres c'est votre dernier livre de jouy
c'est jeunesse aux éditions lattès
bonsoir patrick peloux vous êtes médecin
urgentiste à l'hôpital necker ancien
chroniqueur à charlie hebdo et vous
venez de publier aux éditions du
cherche-midi urgence de vivre qui est un
recueil de vos chroniques
c'est ça on va profiter de la présence
de spécialistes pour parler de vis est
quoi de la copie des plus exactement du
fameux variant anglais qui nous inquiète
ce à juste titre est il vraiment plus
dangereux plus contagieux est-ce que ça
modifie la stratégie sanitaire de la
france on va essayer de défricher un peu
tous ces sujets je vous propose de faire
le point en quelques secondes sur ce
qu'est cette nouvelle souche avec le
professeur bruno mais garbani
c'est le chef de service de réanimation
de l'hôpital lariboisière ils étaient ce
matin chez nos confrères de ses news à
l'échelle individuelle
si on est contaminé par cette souche on
n'a pas plus de risques de faire une
forme grave d'aller en à l'hôpital en
réanimation ou de décéder néanmoins
effectivement à l'échelle de la
population puisque il va y avoir plus de
cas donc mathématiquement il y aura plus
de formes graves donc plus de décès
patrick peloux il n'est pas plus
dangereux mais comme il va plus vite il
est plus inquiétant c'est ça pour ce
résumé déjà comprendre ce que dit mais
des rebelles armés ils signifient ils
veulent tellement être précis il faut
voir les variantes d'accord c'est juste
l'évolution écologique du virus ça a
toujours existé on sait qu'il ya des
variantes en fait à peu près depuis le
mois d'avril
ça a commencé ils ont commencé à dire il
ya des petites variantes c'est là c'est
vrai qu'il ya une variante qui a un peu
plus prononcée en angleterre mais
virus c'est un peu modifié pour
conquérir un petit peu plus de malades
c'est que c'est pour ça donc il est plus
contagieux mais il n'y a pas de
conséquence pour l'instant mais il faut
espérer et toucher du bois pour que ça
soit pas le cas
il est pas plus virulent c'est à dire il
fait pas plus de pathologies où on ne
change pas de pathologie donc on a
toujours les mêmes rappelé d'autre part
par rapport à ce qu'on voit et aux
images qu'on voit à travers le monde qui
sont juste les discours qui lie en
angleterre par exemple nous les strates
des différentes stratégies qui ont eu
lieu ont freiné l'épidémie donc là
l'épidémie est contenue et ce que fait
le son si on traduit ce que fait le
gouvernement il essaye de limiter encore
la contamination avec le couvre-feu là
c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque ce
matin ils ont dit on va par confiner
donc ça c'est ça c'est vraiment la bonne
nouvelle pour l'instant pas là encore on
est on est marche après marche danse
dans ce qui se passe et puis
deuxièmement c'est le front de la
vaccination et ça c'est absolument
important et a priori toutes les
premières études qu'il est notamment
d'angleterre disent bien que le vaccin
couvre pour ses variantes donc voilà on
va pas être plus optimiste que ce qu'il
faudrait mais faut quand même voir un
peu la sortie du tunnel
je ne vais pas dans le sens en effet du
discours par exemple d'axel kahn et
c'est qu'on va tous mourir et c'est
d'accord ou d'autres qui ont un discours
alarmiste parce que je crois et je le
vois dans mon métier j'étais garde cette
nuit nous voyons énormément de
tentatives de suicide
les françaises et français sont tristes
ils sont moroses ils vont pas bien
faut les soutenir il faut la vérité sur
ce qui se passe mais il faut aussi de
l'optimisme
et quand un peu d'optimisme il faut le
donner est-ce que vous partager cet
optimisme sur ce sujet spécifique
oui il va arriver plus jeu
avec mon cher confrère je partage aussi
une inquiétude sur le front de la
jeunesse des dépressions des suicides et
des gens qui en ont ras-le-bol
vous avez d'ailleurs déjà parlé tous les
deux c'est la toise c'est pour ça que la
lenteur de la vaccination me met hors de
moi dire que israël a quasiment fini de
vacciner les gens à risque 20 % de la
population 80 % des seniors
c'est dire que israël a presque fini de
vacciner les gens qui peuvent mourir
qu'on pourra évidemment la durée du
nouveau vaccin
donc là il ya une vraie urgence c'est
cesser d'aller plus vite sur la
vaccination pour protéger les gens le
seul problème mais c'est un tabou on
n'ose pas le dire c'est que la france
n'a pas tu n'as pas de vaccin elle n'a
pas de dose
parce que l'europe qui est pris comme
des glands et l'europe n'a pas commandé
suffisamment des vaccins arn qui sont
les principaux vaccins disponibles à ce
jour là mais qu'il n'avait pas pu y en
avait pas suffisamment mes soucis
l'europe a laissé passer une option
d'achat de 500 millions pendant que
netanyahou le premier ministre israélien
passait dix sept coups de téléphone
personnel au président de pfizer
vous me dire combien d'habitants en
israël c'est beaucoup plus facile il les
a surpayé l'europe à chipoter sur le
prix résultat israël a eu un nombre
illimité de deux doses donc l'europe
c'est vraiment très mal pris mais pour
revenir sur le fond de la discussion
effectivement pour un individu qui elle
va rien anglais ça n'a pas de
conséquence en terme de mortalité mais
ça une conséquence sur la probabilité de
contaminer sa maman sont partagés
puisque effectivement il est plus
contaminant donc il va faire plus de
morts alors je suis d'accord il faut pas
paniquer tout le monde mais il faut bien
qu'on prenne conscience que si le
variant britanniques diffusent en france
nous risquons d'avoir une augmentation
des limitations de liberté et puis
déconfinement parce que nous n'aurons
pas protéger la population ni en france
ni en belgique à avant avant l'été parce
que le rythme de vaccination ne permet
pas à se rapprocher de l'immunité
collective
je suis d'accord
vous mais on s'y est pris comme des
manches
il ya une semaine avec la vaccination
c'était très compliqué avec une
technostructure très pesant tu es aussi
des médecins hospitalo universitaires
qui avait pris la main sur le truc qu'on
ne comprenait rien d'accord avec ce truc
absolument hallucinant qui était de dieu
vous deviez aller voir d'abord un
docteur pour savoir si vous vouliez être
vaccinés et vous devez vous aviez trois
jours pour savoir si vous étiez d'accord
avec le vaccin
donc on ne pouvait pas s'y prendre mieux
pour les complotistes les anti vaccins
etc
en fait il ya un item qui est en dessous
qui est je veux être vaccinés tout de
suite et tout le monde le calme alors il
ya des trucs très positif parce que on
disait que le monde médical était rétif
à à se faire vacciner
là on a ouvert depuis lundi dernier un
centre de vaccination au samu de paris
et à l'hôtel-dieu à paris notamment y en
a dans d'autres hôpitaux mais c'est les
deux que je que que je soutiens où je
travaille et bien vous n'avez aucun
désistement tous ceux qui ont dit je
vais me faire vacciner
illzach side on a les v les médecins
retraités ceux qui sont libéraux ceux
qui traquent tout le monde vient donc ça
je suis assez optimiste
oui je suis optimiste parce qu'en fait
je remet en doute à une partie des
sondages qui disent les français veulent
pas se faire vacciner en fait ils
veulent se faire battre
le seul truc le seul truc je suis pas si
vous êtes d'accord avec moi mais le seul
truc c'est qu'il faut que les
responsables comprennent qu'il faut que
ça soit organisée faut aller vite il
faut vacciner vite les principes des 50
ans moi c'est complètement obsolète il
fallait viser les personnes fragiles et
et pas parler que des personnes âgées
dans les ehpad mais partout et c'est là
parce que la france a cette culture
égalitaire et il fallait l'accès aux
vaincus et puis un point très important
que qui a dit patrice c'est qu'il faut
un message positif
moi personnellement qui suit un ultra
pro vaccin
quand j'ai entendu les premières
interventions d'alain fischer j'avais
presque le mcs faire vacciner le modèle
allemand sur les biens aurait lui aussi
mystères bits mais bien sûr dire si vous
me permettez semin va l'argent on est
d'accord et et est donc aujourd'hui
d'abord il faut faire comme dans les
autres pays il faut que castex se fasse
accident en public même s'il n'est pas
une clé même s'il n'est pas à risque
pour montrer l'exemple comme a fait le
pape comme a fait la reine d'angleterre
comme a fait le nouveau président des
états unis saluent vous vous êtes trop
jeune pour vous faire vacciner malgré le
fait que comme urgente il a ça me plaît
beaucoup à oui ça ne me coûte pas cher
et ça vous fait dire ça vous est plus
jeune que l'aréna bah oui j'ai censuré
pampa c'était dans 50 ans et vous
voudriez fait vacciner oui je suis
vacciné et on va grimper raison des
denrées non non non non non non non
traitement non mais sincèrement
exactement je je enfin on m'a vacciné je
les fais bien sûr pour montrer que me
vacciner sur instagram donc d'accord des
gens religion vue rien sincèrement rien
je vous le dirai rien du tout je vais
très très bien car aucune douleur au
bras rien du tout c'est ce que vous
dites est juste eu le plaisir et
l'honneur d'avoir un entretien d'une
heure avec le premier ministre mercredi
dernier je lui je lui dis je dis vous
devez vous faire vacciner
donc a priori c'est dans les tuyaux mais
il faut que la classe politique se fasse
vacciner
bon là maintenant il ya des enjeux qui
sont de diffuser le plus largement
possible de vaccins et surtout surtout
veillé à ce qu'on n'en manque pas et
puisqu'il a dit jean castex quand vous
lui avez dit pourquoi vous faites pas
vacciner plus vite
il était d'accord mais il y a il y avait
une stratégie de il m'a dit il ya une
stratégie de communication pour dire
c'est pas parce qu'on est ce du pouvoir
qu'on va se vacciner avant moi je trouve
ces tartignole mais bon c'est
complètement tartinables mauvaise parce
que parce que voilà nous nous sommes un
pays profondément régalien et donc par
conséquent il y avait ce besoin de voir
le chef qui se vaccinent donc je me maxi
alors je remarque quand même que vous
avez du mal à parler du patient et du
patient de s'éteint c'est évidemment un
titre de film du variant on ne fait que
parler de ça si on parle du plan de
vaccination et de l'urgence de vacciner
c'est parce que le chariot anglais il va
arriver sur le continent j'ai bien
compris je reviens aux commentaires de
nos internautes si vous le voulez bien
qu'ils sont un peu comme vous d'ailleurs
qu'ils disent
êtes vous êtes vous attendez pardon non
je me trompe voilà on revient avec holly
sur youtube
je suis bien plus inquiet de toutes les
restrictions de liberté que du variant
anglais marv même chose c'est la gestion
du gouvernement qui m'inquiète
et puis notre question twitter donc sur
le hashtag point de vue êtes vous
inquiet par l'évolution du vario anglais
de lakovic 19 oui 56% non 44 minutes par
ac c'est que ça a pas l'air non plus de
2 les bouleverser complètement ça les
bouleverse pas totalement et essai mais
si vous voulez quand vous écoutez un
certain nombre de mes confrères parce
que on peut là vous montez le scénario
catastrophe qui fait que là tout le
monde et liquéfier je suis un bien
humble docteur simple docteur d'accord
je suis pas professeur universitaire et
je parle à la télé c'est à dire que là
il ya des millions de personnes vous
avez à point de vue énormément de
téléspectateurs millions de personnes
qui nous regardent
je suis responsable de ce que je dis
c'est dans le code de déontologie je
dois rassurer les personnes et je dois
pas faire peur ou utiliser bon quand je
vois comme ce matin j'ai oublié son nom
est tant mieux
un médecin sur ces news qui d'un couvent
explique que le vaccin est très
dangereux etc
c'est absolument inadmissible je ne
comprend même pas que le csa l'espace et
ça mais bon c'est terrible et justes et
juste pour terminer la responsabilité de
dire aux gens ou des rassurer ce n'est
pas nier la gravité de la chose on ne
dit pas que le variant n'est pas
potentiellement un sujet c'est un vrai
sujet mais que pour l'instant dans
l'état actuel des connaissances et de la
surveillance épidémiologique y a pas à
s'inquiéter plus mais si vous voulez un
scénario catastrophe et qu'on vous fasse
peur on peut le faire
d'accord mais ça n'a pas d'intérêt oui
bien sûr il y en a qui disent alors oui
en silva riom le vaccin marche pas que
ce terme et c'est faux pour l'instant on
sait que le vaccin fonction six
appareils en quelques minutes si vous le
voulez bien sur les façons dont digue
et la diffusion du vaccin il y en a une
qui serait va peut-être de fermer les
frontières avec le royaume uni
c'est en tout cas ce que préconise un
député des bouches du rhône ce n'est
qu'à marseille on a trouvé des cas de
vario anglais il s'appelle eric diard il
est député les républicains je pense qu
à titre préventif au niveau l'angleterre
principe de précaution il faut fermer
les frontières il n'y a pas de test je
viens d'avoir je suis en commission
actuellement à l'assemblée nationale je
vais d'abord un message d'un collègue
qui me dit j'arrive de lisbonne j'arrive
à l'aéroport de marseille jeu on m'a
rien demandé aucun test
or tant qu'on continuera comme cela mais
les risques de variantes peuvent arriver
d'autant alors soyons précis il ya des
restrictions de circulation entre le
royaume uni et la france vous ne pouvez
entrer en france que si vous rentrez
chez vous si vous êtes en déplacement
professionnel
et si vous avez fourni un test négatif
avant de monter dans l'eurostar sur le
principe laurent alexandre vous qui
vivait entre bruxelles et paris
est ce que vous considérez qu'en fermant
les frontières on diffuserait - le virus
alors aujourd'hui comme le virus est
déjà présent en europe continentale a
massivement présents au danemark en
réalité le sait plus problème le plus le
problème c'est de dépister rapidement le
le vario anglais d' essayer d'isoler les
kloster et puis d'avancer à marche
forcée sur la vaccination
on en revient à l'un de vos auditeurs se
plaignait des mesures liberticides
mais s'il va rien anglais et diffusé sur
le continent on va on va aller vers un
confinement plus hard que le comptines
le confinement de mars 2020 donc en fait
entre vaccination vario anglais et puis
mesures liberticides et confère
confinement il c'est un même et unique
dossier
si le variant arrivons var confiné sauf
si on arrive à vacciner rapidement hélas
nous n'avons pas les doses donc en
réalité le pouvoir je pense devrait
faire ce qu'elle fait netanyahu
netanyahu le premier ministre du 10 raël
a obtenu des millions et des millions et
des millions de doses il a passé 10
coup de téléphone personnel au président
de pfizer mâcon n'a pas appelé 17 fois
le président de pfizer et ils ont eu une
stratégie qui était une stratégie très
agressive de prendre les doses de maximy
lité maximiser les doses pour vacciner
pour vacciner et protéger toute la
population
dans le cas européen en europe
continentale comme l'union européenne
on le disait tout à l'heure n'a pas
commandé à cette dose en réalité on ne
va pas pouvoir lutter contre le variant
britannique par la vaccination
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de doses pour
aller à marche forcée vers l'immunité
collective donc de toute façon sans
aller vers des scénarios catastrophe
il est quand même hélas probable que
dans pas mal de pays du continent
européen
février et mars vont être un tout petit
peu chaud qu'est ce cross sur
lefigaro.fr le dit ferment toutes les
frontières avec le royaume uni
parce que ajoute boxe toujours sur
lefigaro.fr vu comme cela vu comment ça
dégénère en angleterre
nous devrions au minimum être inquiet
non non non faut pas faire ça comme vous
voudrez fort justement de dire il est
déjà en train de se diffuser
vous imaginez on ferme totalement les
frontières de manière hermétique
ça veut dire que les pays doit vivre
vraiment avec juste ce qu'ils produisent
ce qui fait que l'angleterre est affamé
en moins de huit jours
oui d'accord donc du coup c'est pas
possible c'est c'est pas entendable
c'est vraiment de la politique à la
petite semaine c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut alors moi je
moi je pense que c'est pas le rôle du
chef de l'état d'appeler le patron de
pfizer par contre c'est le rôle du chef
de l'état d'organiser les choses pour
que on est des vaccins ça voilà moi je
pense que ça juste pour accessoirement
guillaume
n'oublions pas que il ya des vaccins et
des composantes vaccins qui sont
fabriqués en angleterre si on ferme
complètement la frontière voilà nous
n'aurons plus de vaccins
donc il ya deux choses il ya
premièrement réussir à avoir des chaînes
de production du vaccin en france
si j'ai bien compris il y travaille si
j'ai bien compris c'était compliqué de
comprendre véran l'autre jour mais a
priori cesser ce qui est en train d'être
décidé de fait d'accord deuxièmement il
ya d'autres vaccins qui vont arriver
mais il faut qu'ils des vaccins en
nombre et en nombre suffisant parce que
les gens demandent à être vaccinés donc
il ya une véritable attente y ait de
véritables attentes et redire que
pendant ce temps là pendant qu'on
vaccine faux
des gestes barrières et c'est à cette
condition là pour répondre à votre
internaute qui parlait des libertés
individuelles
c'est si on garde ses 2 ces deux combats
simultanée qu'on évitera le leur
confinement qui étaient dévastateurs je
le répète y compris on a à peu près six
mois de retard à l'heure actuelle sur
les coloscopies qui veut dire six mois
pour le dépistage d'un cancer qu'on
guérit quand vous faites votre
coloscopie donc voyez il ya tout ça
c'est à dire que là on est face à des
échéances en termes sanitaires sociales
psychiques et psychiatriques qui sont
absolument considérable il faut tout
mener de front c'est bien enregistrées
en particulier les préconisations sur
les gestes barrières comme y avait un
passé pro mais à bientôt mais pas tout
de suite parce qu'il nous reste encore
un sujet si vous le voulez bien
donald trump avec 87 millions de
followers comme on dit en bon français
sur twitter il y en a plus un seul
puisque le réseau social la censure et à
la suite de ces dernières déclarations
et des derniers événements notamment
celui de l'émeute du capitole s c'est un
acte de civisme que de fermer le compte
twitter du président des états unis ou
au contraire un acte de censure voici
deux points de vue pour éclairer le
vôtre le premier est prudemment contre
la décision de twitter c'est barbara
pompili la ministre de la transition
écologique
je comprends la réaction mais je pense
que ça ne peut pas être une réaction
normale
on doit avoir des processus
démocratiques pour réguler le
fonctionnement des plateformes des
réseaux sociaux
et ça ça doit faire l'objet de débats
politiques et ça doit faire l'objet de
règles de régler
et après la ministre prudemment contre
voici l'eurodéputé résolument contre la
décision de twitter c'est
françois-xavier bellamy je crois qu'il
faut que tous ceux qui sont attachés à
la liberté quelle que soit leur opinion
sur donald trump tire aujourd'hui le
signal d'alarmé
le président des états unis en exercice
et chassé de tous les réseaux sociaux
tous ce qui veut dire fondamentalement
que nous rentrons dans un monde où les
seules opinions légitimes seront
hébergés sur les lieux où se déroulent
aujourd'hui qu'on le veuille ou non une
partie du débat démocratique
alors allez vous vous êtes toujours
actif sur twitter et on s'en réjouit et
vous avez twitté hier qu' il s'agit d'un
véritable coup d'état des géants du
numérique contre le pouvoir politique
bien sûr c'est un coup d'état
électronique
quand vous avez les géants du numérique
tous ensemble jusqu'à pâques twitter on
coupe le sifflet donald trump et
supprime tous les messages qui viennent
de l'homme le plus puissant du monde le
président en exercice
il est toujours président en exercice
est un vrai coup d'état numérique
manquera t il ya il y a des raisons du
point de vue des plates formes east il y
a des raisons de couper le sifflet à
trump
mais c'est quand même un coup d'état
c'est la preuve que les géants du
numérique sont plus puissants que le
pouvoir politique
ça ne va pas durer le pouvoir politique
va se venger dans l'est dans les années
qui viennent mais on n'a pas
suffisamment réfléchi à l'immense
pouvoir des géants du numérique et de
l'intelligence artificielle à toutes les
filiales qu'ils construisent à tous les
domaines dans lequel y rentrer amazon le
président d'amazon à un gigantesque
programme spatial pour construire des
stations orbitales géante dans le
système solaire est le must qui est
aussi un géant de l'électronique a
débloqué hier à des projets en matière
spatiale et de colonisation de mars a
développé une sociaux une société pour
mettre des implants intra cérébraux dans
dans nos cerveaux on voit que healy a
aujourd'hui un immense pouvoir médical
éducatif médiatique des géants du
numérique et la régulation des géants du
numérique n'a pas n'a pas été réfléchie
on a en ce moment
apple amazon google qui rentrent
massivement dans la santé aux états unis
ça a des conséquences importantes il
faut que les médecins ils réfléchissent
et imagine le monde de demain
est ce qu'un docteur google c'est un
modèle positif ou pas comment doit-on
réguler docteur apple ou docteur amazon
dans les décennies qui viennent il y à
un débat politique autour du pouvoir
absolument gigantesque des spécialistes
du numérique et de l'intelligence
artificielle pouvoir dont on doit
rappeler votre modestie dut-elle en
souffrir que vous l'aviez annoncé ou
diagnostiquer ou pronostiqué avant les
autres puisque en 2011 vous avez écrit
un livre qui s'applique google
démocratie et qui justement on voit la
couverture à l'instant à l'écran
anticipaient ce qui est en train de nous
arriver
patrick pelloux est ce que si vous avez
été le patron twitter vous auriez ou non
coupé le compte d'un altran est
évidemment vous l'auriez coupé
évidemment écoutez c'est il ya une
différence entre l'action politique et
la psychiatrie
là vous êtes dans un domaine
psychiatrique
c'est à dire que la donald trump va
partir de la maison blanche qui va aller
parler à winnie l'ourson tout le restant
de sa vie ça sera très bien
il aura ses petits jouets ces petits
machins défaut portable ça sera très
bien là la gaffe des états unis a était
d'élire quelqu'un qui était totalement
inadaptée et inappropriée qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il s'est passé que d'un coup
il a réussi alors c'est ça qui est
inquiétant en fait 71 millions de
personnes ont voté pour lui ont voté
pour un type qui a vraiment pris le
pouvoir et qui est au compte de sa folie
c'est une folie qui une folie que les
américains j'ai fait un débat sur radio
canada samedi avec avec un médecin de
boston qui étaient là et qui
m'expliquait le chaos complet qu'il y a
aux etats unis avec l'épidémie de l'aco
vide et vous avez quand même un
président des etats-unis qui a nié
qu'ils nient encore le fait qu' à cette
épidémie pourtant il a été malade ils
l'ont soigné fort heureusement pour lui
avec des techniques qu'on ne connaît pas
trop baisser vu voilà peu importe mais
il y là il s'en est sorti
ce qui fait qu là pour moi le fait de
l'avoir enlevée c'était évident
et de galvaniser des foules parce qu'on
sait où ça conduit la galvanisation des
foules comme ça bon maintenant je suis
d'accord avec vous il faut une politique
va reprendre la main là dessus parce que
maintenant c'est dans l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est comme si on disait on
va supprimer le téléphone c'est
impossible
bon bah voilà les réseaux sociaux ou
peut-être dire pour certains réseaux
asociaux d'accord et qui vous détruisent
parce que quand vous êtes sur twitter et
on sait que la après ce qu'on a dit on
va avoir des gens qui vont nous insulter
moi je reçois régulièrement des menaces
de mort zineb el rhazoui ancien de
charlie hebdo et moi à au moment du
procès on a reçu des menaces de mort on
a augmenté notre sécurité
donc c'est quand vous allez à la police
et que vous dites je suis menacé de mort
ne se passe pas grand chose
il a fallu attendre que et la
mobilisation de darmana contre baraka
city et le cicf pour dire voilà parce
que vous avez les franges et notamment
les islamistes les fascistes les fachos
islamistes ont bien compris comment ça
marchait et qui font des manipulations
je reviens au k donald trump
laurent alexandre que répondez-vous à
cet argument de patrick peloux donald
trump était fou il donc c'était une
mesure entre guillemets de salubrité
publique bien sûr que de le faire alors
des fous on est d'accord mais ce que je
constate c'est que la censure contre
donald trump de la part des réseaux
sociaux a encore augmenté le délire d'un
complot d'ascendance étaient cinglés
d'accord donc là les complotistes et les
singles et ne cesse de répéter en boucle
c'est bien la preuve qu'il y avait un
complot satanisme mondial de l'état
profond contre trump regarder et le
complot a réussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile
je suis très partagé sur cette affaire
je partage le point de vue de deux
de peloux sur le caractère psychiatrique
de trump et sur les délires qu'il induit
notamment chez ses soutiens chez les
oies notes qui sont totalement délirant
mais en même temps le censurer a un
effet secondaire dramatique qui est de
renforcer le délire le délire des
cinglés des groupes l'autisme donc c'est
un équilibre très difficile il juste
rappelé par avoir un à ce que vous
voulez dire c'est que la santé mentale
aux etats unis elle est totalement nié
un tas dire que quand vous vous promenez
notamment à los angeles ou à san
francisco vous voyez des grands malades
délirant qui traînent on n'a pas ça en
france vous avez un balade délirant qui
traînent dans la rue y va être conduit
au secteur au secteur en hôpital
psychiatrique
il va avoir un traitement il sera
potentiellement mis dans une structure
s'il ya de la place évidemment là c'est
un autre débat mais il se passe quelque
chose là bas c'est et quand vous voyez
ces images là moi je veux bien que après
les états unis sont foutus nous avec les
gilet jaune en montrant des cartes de
france qui brûlait nous on n'a jamais vu
ça en france
vous n'avez jamais eu les gilet jaune
qui ont envahi l'elysée parce qu'il ya
eu un maintien de l'ordre d'accord il ya
eu des violences policières ça c'est sûr
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait en france on
réfléchit vous n'avez pas autant de
morts tués par la police en france que
ce que vous avez aux états unis donc
c'est un pays qui donne sans arrêt des
leçons parce que j'ai beaucoup aimé ça a
été la réaction de pays africains qui
ont conquis ont recommandé aux états
unis de de suivre leur exemple en termes
de démocratie
ça c'était très drôle ça c'était très
drôle et pendant que vous parlez on voit
les images tournées par vincent joly
l'envoyé spécial du figaro magazine qui
était au coeur de cette séquence
incroyable
il était entré dans le capital en même
temps que les émeutiers vous avez pu le
suivre en direct sur sugar alive mené
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
vous savez si en fait les organes les
organisateurs et ceux qui détiennent les
réseaux sociaux ne font pas le ménage
neuneu notamment ne veuille pas à des
expressions qui sont racistes
belliqueuse fasciste comme l'islam au
fascisme etc etc
ils vont s'auto détruire en fait parce
qu'en effet les démocraties vont réagir
et vont probablement sur réagir vous
avez vu certains états comme la chine
par exemple un qui n'est pas une
démocratie c'est pas une démocratie
complètement d'accord mais la chine qui
d'un coup a fermé et a mis en résidence
surveillée le patron d'alibaba samedi
que tous les deux que vous étiez
partager cet intéressant parce que nos
internautes aussi c'est la question du
jour
sur le figaro.fr approuvez vous la
décision de twitter de bagnols en ahl
trump et c'est oui à 52 30 % et il ya
144 mille votants autant vous dire que
alors c'est un c'est un sujet qui a
intéressé les internautes du figaro vous
disiez à l'instant laurent alexandre que
les états n'allait pas se laisser faire
mais il n'est pas déjà trop tard pour
essayer de réguler twitter ou facebook
les plateformes sont incontournables
elles rendent un service absolument
extraordinaire il s'agit pas de dire que
du mal des de google apple facebook
amazon et et les autres donc il va y
avoir du fait de l'hyperpuissance des
géants de l'intelligence artificielle
il va y avoir des régulations étatiques
et elles sont tellement importantes pour
la société ses plates formes qu'elles
vont être régulés il ne s'agit pas
d'interdire mais il s'agit de les
réguler par exemple de leur interdire de
fermer des comptes sans demander l'avis
d'une autorité indépendante quelque
chose qu'il va il va y avoir des
autorités indépendantes pour réguler le
droit de parole
il va y avoir des procédures judiciaires
pour pouvoir empêcher la fermeture de
son compte par un des géants de
l'intelligence artificielle
tout ça va se construire dans les
décennies qui viennent mais il faut bien
voir que le phénomène des des réseaux
sociaux ça à 10 ans il n'est pas anormal
qu'on était dépassé du fait de
l'évolution technologique et qu'on soit
un petit peu en retard en matière de
régulation
je pense qu'il va falloir des décennies
pour réguler cette économie de
l'intelligence artificielle on va pas
faire ça d'un claquement de doigts
l'épisode du capitole est un électrochoc
en ce sens qu'il montre la puissance de
ces plateformes qui en réalité sont les
rédacteurs en chef du monde mais il faut
que les états la première chose à faire
c'est que quand vous êtes insulté menacé
de mort sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense notamment avec les signalements
sur le radicalisme islamique sur la
plateforme pharos
il faut qu'ils aient des moyens ça veut
dire que là il ya un rôle régalien de
l'état qui doit se créer ou se déporter
avec une vigilance particulière et je
pense aussi à toutes les escroqueries
etc
donc il ya toute une nouvelle
délinquance qui est en train d'arriver
et on a l'impression en fait que les
états sont très contemplatif par rapport
à ça alors qu'il devrait avoir un tour
d'avancé les états et les les réseaux
sociaux mais iraizoz effectivement à
chaque fois que contient le genre de
propos que vous venez d'avoir on a des
internautes qui le disent mais pas du
tout on peut retrouver l'adresse ip des
gens qui sont sur twitter ni twitter est
très réticent pour la donner et wii 2
ensuite c'est très long très long plus
très de la chair je réponds parce que ça
m'est arrivé plus d'une fois avec les
menaces de mort que j'ai que je reçois
assez régulièrement
c'est très compliqué par la police ça
doit aller vers à un bureau spécial de
la police qui a des monticules entier de
recherche d'adressés ip et après comme
vous le savez l'adresse ip elle est très
volage donc c'est extrêmement compliqué
voilà on est très content que c'est pour
vos prises de position courageuses
contre l'islamisme et les dérives
séparatistes que vous faites l'objet de
telles menaces
laurent alexandre pour terminer avec 7
points de vue d'un internaute qui nous
dit il n'y a pas de sang sur twitter est
une entreprise privée elle fait ce
qu'elle veut avec son produit
je répondais oui alors en réalité non
les géants de l'intelligence
artificielle ont un rôle qui dépasse le
rôle normal d'une entreprise privée
ils ont un pouvoir immense et du fait de
cette immense pouvoir
ce ne sont pas des entreprises normales
ce sont des entreprises qui ont un
pouvoir géopolitique
ce sont en réalité deux nouveaux objets
géopolitique
ce sont des corporations elles ont un
pouvoir identique au pouvoir d etat l
elles maîtrisent un territoire qui est
un nouveau territoire qui est le
cyberespace est donc en réalité ce sont
des acteurs qui sont davantage des
acteurs de nature étatiques et
géopolitique que des acteurs privés
traditionnels et canton
on doit réguler des acteurs
géopolitiques on a un droit particulier
qui n'est pas le droit d entreprise
privée traditionnel donc on ne peut pas
appliquer le droit des entreprises
privées à des acteurs qui sont davantage
des acteurs géopolitiques que des
acteurs privés normaux merci merci
beaucoup à tous les deux ce débat était
passionnant merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi et rendez vous demain même heure
même endroit pour une nouvelle édition
de point de vue
[Musique]